After my best activities, I've been working with a physical therapist to prevent lymphedema.
No problems with that, but I am getting
cordy, which feels like cords that run from my underarms to my mid-opera part.
The PT's are working with me, but can't explain why this happens. Do you know?
And is there anything else I could do? Well, it's a matter of just doing everything possible to help move
the lymph corded occurs when you have blockage because it can almost always occurs when you've
had blockage because you have removed lymph nodes or post surgery. So just keep working on that.
These will go away adema settles in your tissues and in the fascia layer as well.
Just keep working on it. You've got to be patient with it too. Don't try to push it too hard
and you can irritate things too. And if you're doing heavy deep tissue massage or something,
you could actually be irritating the tissues and causing more adema. So you've got to go gentle with them.